IT’S UNLIKELY SUCH EFFORTS WOULD
BEAR FRUIT IN TIME TO MATTER.
>> Shannon: JOHN ROBERTS,
THANK YOU.
IT WAS ANOTHER DAY OF INCREDIBLE
VOLATILITY ON WALL STREET.
LIKE YESTERDAY, SWINGS OF
HUNDREDS OF POINTS WERE COMMON.
UNLIKE YESTERDAY, THERE IS MUCH
MORE MOVEMENT UP AND DOWN.
THE DOW FINISHED AHEAD 567
POINTS AFTER TAKING A NOSEDIVE
AT THE START OF THE DAY.
S&P 500 UP 46.
NASDAQ REGAINED 148.
LET’S FIND OUT WHAT THIS WAS ALL
ABOUT.
DEIRDRE BOLTON OF FOX NEWS
NETWORK, FOX BUSINESS NETWORK,
JOINS US.
GOOD EVENING.
>> GOOD EVENING.
VOLATILITY IS BACK.
YOU GAVE THE CLOSING LEVELS, BUT
DURING THE DAY, THE DOW SWUNG
1200 POINTS, IF YOU CAN BELIEVE
THAT.
IT CHANGED DIRECTION 29 TIMES.
DEFINITE WHIPLASH FOR TRADERS.
TREASURY SECRETARY STEVEN
MNUCHIN SPOKE EARLIER SAYING
THERE’S A LARGER ECONOMIC
PICTURE TO CONSIDER.
>> WE ARE VERY FOCUSED ON THE
LONG-TERM ECONOMIC GROWTH AND WE
BELIEVE THE POLICIES WE’VE
ENACTED INCLUDING TAX REFORM ARE
VERY POSITIVE FOR LONG-TERM
ECONOMIC GROWTH.
>> THE U.S. ECONOMY HAS SUCH
STRONG UNDERPINNINGS THAT SOME
STRATEGIES SAY THAT’S WHAT
STARTED THE SELLING.
INVESTORS HAVE A 17 YEAR LOW FOR
UNEMPLOYMENT, RISING WAGE
GROWTH, AND MANY THOUGHT IT
WOULD FORCE THE FED TO RAISE
RATES HIGHER OR QUICKER OR EVEN
BOTH.
MAKING BORROWING OF ALL KINDS
MORE EXPENSIVE.
ANALYST POINT OUT THAT THE
SELLING HAS BEEN EXACERBATED BY
PROGRAM TRADING, COMPUTER-DRIVEN
TRADES THAT KICK IN
AUTOMATICALLY WHEN MARKETS HIT
CERTAIN LEVELS.
>> WHAT WE HAVE SEEN IS CLEARLY
A SELL-OFF THAT’S BEEN DRIVEN TO
A LARGE EXTENT BY ALGORITHMS AND
COMPUTER TRADING.
WE GET THESE REVERSALS, AND WHEN
WE GET THEM, FROM THE MAJOR
TREND, THEY ARE SHARP, STEEP,
QUICK AND ALWAYS PAINFUL.
BUT I THINK AT THE MOMENT,
SHOULD BE VIEWED AS TECHNICAL
BECAUSE NOTHING FUNDAMENTAL HAS
REALLY CHANGED.
>> ECONOMIC INDICATORS SUCH AS
THE U.S. TRADE DEFICIT ARE MORE
LIKELY TO CATCH A PROFESSIONAL
INVESTOR’S EYE.
THE U.S. TRADE DEFICIT GREW TO
ITS WIDEST IN NINE YEARS TODAY.
MEANS THE U.S. IS BUYING MORE
GOODS THAN IT IS TELLING.
IF THAT TREND CONTINUES, IT
COULD HURT AMERICAN
MANUFACTURING.
THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION IS
COMMITTED TO ADDRESSING TRADE
ISSUES.
NEXT UP, ANOTHER ROUND OF
MEETINGS ON NAFTA IN MARCH.
LOTS OF ECONOMIC INDICATORS TO
WATCH, INCLUDING THE POSSIBILITY
OF A SHUTDOWN IN D.C. WHICH I